how about like Sexton my talk is on CSS
colors specifically the named ones and I
know we deep dive into a lot of
technical stuff a lot so I wanted to
deep dive into some history so there's
not a lot of code in this talk but
hopefully you find it pretty interesting
I do the colors black and white I
realized that's a mistake now what are
they Webster's dictionary defines a
color as so I was going to do the
Webster's dictionary defines joke but I
didn't have to because this is a real
website for the Webster's dictionary and
it's pretty it's the worst website I've
ever been to
so that's the real joke stay in school
so color it says is a quality such as
red blue green yellow
etc that you see when you look at
something so now that we have that
background
what's x11 can't really understand what
x11 is without understanding a few other
things first namely letters and numbers
we're more specifically a letter and a
number of which the set is x + 1 X 11 is
this sweet gooey I haven't actually read
what's on that screen I hope it's cool X
set seems it seems very relevant that
was on purpose
the colors here it looked like various
greys maybe a black or to the the teal
looking color is a light C green MIT
specifically the MIT Media Lab was
pretty infiltrated with like a bunch of
companies in Boston at the time namely
Deccan Tektronix so you'll see a lot of
those people show up but MIT Media labs
where it's at that's where X was created
so the first colors show up in RGB txt
in actually x10 so if anyone tries to
call
x11 colors they're absolutely right but
you could like undermine them and tell
them well actually the colors come from
x10 r3 it's not as catchy so 1987 was
actually the first release august 18th
1987 i think i was two months old at the
time
there were 69 colors in RGB txt and when
i first wrote the slides for this no one
really knew the original author of the
RGB txt file but since then the x.org
organization reached out to me and let
me know that it was jim gettys
so thanks x.org sweet fix for my
presentation
there are 138 entries because well at
the time because they did a camel case
and lower case spaced as well because of
course you would they were listed in
mostly alphabetical order and they were
tuned for the deck VT 240 serious
terminals that is one it looks very
green that's because the color they were
using there was green and that was it
so March 24th 1988 seven months after
the first release very close to my
birthday its March 13th for those of you
with pens and paper was a huge release
for colours we added three new colors
brown gray and gray and you you may be
thinking that sounds a lot like a law
firm but these were the colors in x11 r2
and you may also be thinking hey that
brown looks red and are those Gray's the
same color the brown is very red and
those Gray's are the same color gray
spelled both ways was intentionally
added because some programmers at HP
couldn't remember which one was right
for the record in the States
it's a and in England
it's ESO America and England they start
with the right letter for for you this
is all domestic at the time though so it
should have probably never made it in
yeah so update literally this morning
five hours ago when I put this slide
again so maybe
ten hours now chrome blink added all the
ease it traditionally didn't work in
browsers this happened this is new
history this morning literally this
morning you can now use geo re UI more
of that I thought they should have done
this though if you're going to go for it
go all the way so October 27 1988 was
released three there are a hundred and
one variants of gray added this is my
101 dalmatians joke slide very cruel
Cruella Corolla whatever the hundred and
one variants of gray were suggested and
added by mark mores this was he was from
the University of Toronto September 3rd
1988 was when he was added I didn't go
back to find this picture this is the
picture that he currently has on his
current site the hundred and one Gray's
were gray zero gray one grade to grade
three I have some more slides they were
in this very clear 3-2 interval you know
3 5 8 10 13 15 18 sorry I thought the
intervals were funny except for that a
month and a half later I don't know why
it took so long but a month and a half
later they went in and added all the
misspellings too so there are actually
two hundred two grades there were like
eight commits in between adding the
grades and adding the ease like it's
just like too much to type I guess so
luckily those are all now in CSS color
level 4 you just have to add parens and
percentages and it's actually pretty
close to what it used to be still
disappointed also in this release
they moved white from 252 across the
board to 255 across the board very
important fix
I wonder what 255 255 255 was called
before my suggestions were really white
or light white
they did that because white now equals
gray 100 before gray 100 was whiter than
white that's what a lot of people say
about me too
this a commit actually just after that
release was the introduction of sandy
brown which is one of my favorite colors
this is one of 40 commits their 40
commits total RGB txt and this is one of
them all they did was add sandy brown in
the commit message just added sandy
brown and you may notice like hey
there's something wrong with that so
over two months later one of the other
of the 40 commits is they fixed the
camel casing in sandy brown very
important color I hope you're still
using it five percent of all commits to
RGB txt are sandy brown related I
personally like sandy brown though
because there's gotta be like a thousand
sandy Browns that exist
like people have no idea that their acts
11 color specifically this guy has no
idea he kind of looks sandy brown - for
what it's worth
1989 was like a huge release not in the
joking way that I've already made twice
in a real way we got Alice blue which is
white on these projectors Alice blue is
named after Alice in Wonderland's dress
that's a fun one
there's blanched almond this fuchsia
there's Thomas fuchsia lemon chiffon
papaya whip peach puff those were just a
list of some of my favorites but this
this was where the the the real people
came together Paul raveling and John C
Thomas were these two dudes on the x
windows mailing list and Jim Fulton was
the maintainer of the filed so these
three people together kinda had this
culmination of new ideas on how we
should name colors Jim I actually talked
crap about the last time I talked about
this I now that I have all the commits
he did some good stuff this is my
favorite Jim Fulton commit
he took out transparent which was pretty
much
black and not transparent it was just
not quite black which so as long as your
backgrounds are black transparent should
look fine for you I guess the second
pass Jim Fulton commit was removed blank
line
boy what a stupid program that's 2.5
percent of our DB T X T so the raveling
RGB txt his version of the colors come
from comp table window said X this news
group before we had forums and really a
lot of other stuff on October 1989 it
was tuned to match his specific HP
monitor so everything you used today is
tuned specifically to one dudes HP
monitor from 1989 and he when he when he
said that he did give a model number
either so I'm just assuming there was
one HP monitor at the time it was a
response to one of his co-workers that
said that's wheat and so he took it upon
himself to change the color of wheat so
it looked more like wheat and so he went
and he said a lot of the names came from
Sinclair paint swatches that he had from
recently paying his house
this is Sinclair paints green enamel
specifically the Sinclair oil company is
that a dinosaur logo at the bottom they
were sold in 1994 by Sinclair oil for 51
million dollars because they violated
the childhood lead poisoning prevention
Act of 1991 he's quoted saying by the
way I wanted to find ansi standard
colors but ANSI happily gobbled up my 16
dollars without sending the
specification I ordered then they
ignored my follow-up letter nuts to ANSI
and scare quotes ANSI standards so you
use papaya whip because ANSI never sent
Paul raveling some mail this is where we
moved away from mostly alphabetical
order as well he did some rearranging he
added a gradient approach to color
groups so he'd have chocolate which is a
color and saddle brown which is a color
but then he added chocolate one two
three four and those colors were like
what is it logarithmic steps darker from
from the original colors but
unfortunately those would sometimes
clash with colors that already existed
and so there would be like two names for
the same color like chocolate four was
the same as saddle brown in this case
and so I looked for a chocolate saddle
brown and that's what came up I would
imagine that's chocolate saddle brown
for specifically the Thomas RGB dxt
submitted on Halloween 1989 to the list
that's probably good Halloween joke it
was a response to an email sent to the
list titled this is pink so the two
lists that we use come from this is
wheat and this is pink I thought I was
interesting so this is it the best
section is the pink color in particular
looks like the flesh tone of someone
who's been puking for several hours
would really rather get a bullet in the
head than go on living and so Jhansi
Thomas I responded and the key section
here he says advised by our human
factors folks that standard color of
named colors exist but only for
well-controlled color coordinate systems
like CIE but not for RGB I sat down one
evening with the handiest standard of
subjective color names a box of 72
Crayola Crayons and then he said believe
it or not 50% of the colors from RGB txt
were represented already crayons this is
where x11 colors come from for the most
part you might notice he said 72 a handy
box at 72 crayons and I knew them as a
box of 64 as a kid and I wondered to
myself where is this magical box at 72
in which colors did he pull from it so I
went and I found this is 72 krantz what
had happened is they retired some colors
and then they had left over once so they
put them in a box with the new ones and
called it a collector's edition so they
could get rid of them they're currently
worth over $7 on eBay here are the list
of retired colors you may recognize all
of them as colors that didn't make it
into CSS or even x11 colors so
they ended up not mattering at all and
he could have said box of 64 so it's
really a very worthless part of the
tongue
these sense retired colors in crayons
that still made it into CSS colors even
our Navajo white and Indian red a lot of
people ask are these colors racist and
I'll preface this with the intent isn't
isn't magical is a good phrase here so
even if they aren't and people are
offended by them that we should address
it but Navajo white is the exact shade
of color on the back of the Navajo flag
now someone could have doctored that
because if you read the last sentence in
this slide or in Wikipedia here it says
in 1987 which is wrong the colored
Navajo white was included in the x11
color list which is not a thing which
after the invention of the World Wide
Web in 1991 which is the wrong year
became known as the x11 web colors which
don't exist so someone should edit that
Wikipedia page Indian red oh also Navajo
white is FF dead pretty sweet RVT
yeah Indian red actually showed up in
the UK in 1792 and it's referring to
like like rust oxide type stuff so
totally before that was really a slur
so that was likely both of those are
probably not racist
initially Peru on the other hand is a
bit of more of a mystery I could find
pretty much no information I was like ah
what what color is the Peruvian flag
it's red and white so I went to
Wikipedia and I saw on the brown page
there is a link on the color rather on
the x11 page it links to slash Browns
hash Peru and I was like here's where
I'll get my information that doesn't
exist
the only thing I could do is a command F
for the word Peru on the brown page and
it comes up under the skin color section
so Peru is probably racist not the
country the color Krantz that's where we
were so this is pink so over 50% of the
colors were already represented but
we're guessing that that's probably
because green and blue and red and
yellow are pretty popular names for
colors so very important Thomas change
was he removed medium goldenrod but
luckily he added pale goldenrod dark
goldenrod light goldenrod yellow and
light goldenrod I'm not sure what the
difference between those last two were
so these are all in Compton windows
Eric's the second half of this talk is
kind of me reading a lot of emails but
hopefully it's worth it to you so Paul
vixie the creator of the more more
well-known Quran the Quran you use today
posts probably before he was doing too
much with crime and he he created the
first color picker with x11 and he
called his color picker reasonably cute
I just thought that was nice
he also posts a bunch of code directly
into an email on a news group and I
thought that was like throwback github
1988 this is Bob he nails probably the
best joke on the whole list I read
pretty much every email on this list
there's like 200 posts a year guys so
Bob nails this joke someone asks as a
joke they're trying to be sarcastic they
say could someone please mail the recent
message about using the definitive
restaurant standard box of 64 crayons
with the built-in sharpener and Bob
slyly responds back the available
reference which someone else posted
already was based on the 72 cran
standard so it was important a later
ANSI Rev than the 64 cran standard but I
think it will serve your purposes the
ISO 497 cran standard is still in
committee the French delegation raised
objections to the standard pronunciation
of muave so it may be a while longer in
the meantime the 72 box is useful
lighter weight fits in more regularly
shaped box easier to keep sharp less
costly as a replacement time due to
meltdown or
cutting slash tattooing and universally
available even though it's not an
international standard Larry well the
creator of Perl suggests that instead of
naming these silly ways how about we all
get a curve fitting program and match
this really confusing system for having
your own personal colors tuned to your
own personal monitor which is a pretty
good idea but about as confusing as Perl
and then he says that he's not going to
write it but at the time he did work for
NASA which is pretty cool so good on him
Jet Propulsion lab actually that's what
the JPL stands for the first is it
racist thread showed up at this time in
1992 it was mostly people not
understanding why the initial guy
thought it was racist and then other
people getting really mad pretty much
the same as today and this person came
in and said hey wouldn't it be cool if
we named these colors a little bit
better and she was two years before all
those other people and then no one ever
responded to her email and she missed
out on her opportunity so five years
past we have the next version of x11 rr5
and we changed gray from 192 to 190
across the board and that was the last
official x11 RGB txt update so how does
this relate to CSS here are some CSS
colors all of them they're 140 x11
colors and they were specified in css3
which seems like whoa that seems pretty
recent except for that css3
was of course started in 2001 which is
kind of blew my mind so March 5th 2001
tantek posts the list of x11 color
keywords on here and they were really
just codifying web browsers had already
done for years and no one wanted it and
they were all really mad about it on the
mailing list the hue distribution was
wrong we saw a different prettier graph
of this earlier this one comes out of a
fun email there are already some HTML
colors and this is kind of what Leia
talked about before and they mostly
clashed and so like you'll see like with
lime versus green
gray versus gray we had to make way to
use the old colors we couldn't we
couldn't use it
so first mention of x11 colors
specifically in CSS dates back to 96 by
Chris Lilley he was kind of an [ __ ]
and most of his posts but he was right
so I think that's probably what it takes
to be good in the standards
organizations so also note that just
like before this is his picture on his
current website
I took it right off his website and I
actually think that they're the same
pair of glasses that mark mores the 101
greatest guy wore I think they shared
those and then promised each other that
they would never update their pictures
the WWE style mailing list was also
hilarious this is a good one this is
Chris Lilley again someone says to base
a color model on the basic set of
crayons used by euro protocol children
seems short sighted and he said it would
be if anyone was proposing it I'm not
are you
that was him not realizing that indeed
he was proposing it he just didn't know
where that came from and this guy this
one's not that interesting except for
that he thinks the reason we should use
CMYK is because the the largest use case
is for websites is printing them out I
actually laughed out loud whenever I
read that Dylan she even the co-creator
of dojo wrote this nice email whenever
they were getting kind of added to css3
and he's like you're all these old posts
in these archives about everyone
disagree with it so I can't find him and
supports them I don't understand why we
do it I don't understand why these
colors exists and why they're so poorly
named like what is this system that
we're using and so his his question in
2002 was recently responded to by me in
2014
I said hey Dylan sorry for the short
delay in responding to this but I looked
into where the x11 colors came from and
thought I'd answer your question also I
was only 16 when you asked and Google
hadn't quite index all the old x11 news
group
so it's unlikely that a good helped you
at the time and here's my favorite email
probably in the entire list I already
apologized for reading email to you but
again this is from Steven Pemberton who
also was still pretty active not
necessarily with CSS anymore or stumped
he says congratulations on an excellent
specification many of the new facilities
will be extremely useful with one
exception the x11 color names are an
abomination that should have been
stifled at Birth and adding them to CSS
as a blemish on the otherwise excellent
design of CSS questionable to say that
x11 color set and their names have been
designed is an insult to the word design
it's just a mess let me describe some of
the problems the set of colors described
is very non-uniform look at and that's
his old graph from before very thank you
thankful for that as an example to see
how the hues are distributed a vast
over-representation of reds just to
start off with the names are just
randomly put together some colors have a
dark version like red and dark red but
not all 17 colors have dark versions but
only 13 have light versions there's a
medium blue but not medium red there are
15 varieties of blue but only 6 of red
there are cultural references built in
Dodger blue later switched to royal blue
so I can neither construct the color I
want nor know the color name refers to
Gainsborough papaya whip on top of that
the naming scheme is inconsistent dark
grey is lighter than gray light pink is
darker than pink ok I'll stop using
exclamation marks now he he doesn't say
that he's stopped using punctuation at
all but he goes ahead and does that - it
is grey and dark grey but like grey with
an e not anymore
as of today brown is not very brown
actually a dark red what do you expect
the difference is between see green and
medium C cream sea green is darker what
do you expect the difference between
aquamarine and medium aquamarine
aquamarine is lighter there's a medium
violet red in a pale violet red but no
violet red
there's a light goldenrod yellow but no
goldenrod yellow just goldenrod there's
dark olive green but no olive green just
olive
there's pale violet red but no violet
red I'd like to submit an errata first
that's the first period in ten lines but
he also he mentions that there's no
violet there's no violet right on the
first line of that four bar stanza so
see you in if you're watching please fix
that well I could go on but I'll stop
here he does go on you get the picture
there's no possible reason that the x11
names should be added to CSS and then he
goes on to propose I'm actually pretty
good ideas that I think kind of are
being realized in the new stuff that
like I talked about today so yeah go
Steven Pemberton in 2002 Hicks each arms
in with what I assume is his
autoresponder these are merely added to
CSS to codify current practices almost
everybody our browser already supports
them it's not going to change so we
might as well codify it that's that's
the in Hickson autoresponder we're just
doing what everyone already does get off
my back
and then the the final email that I
found that I thought was interesting was
what if we could make our own system of
color mappings so we can implement
unique mappings like say crayons so the
final email is someone suggesting that
maybe we can name our colors after
crayons instead of whatever they're
currently named after so Owens with
crayons so I like to end with my
favorite commit boy
what a stupid program
you